I played inspector stop on it's a fun  character you know I mean he's a drunk  Detective from Scotland Yard and he is  lucky enough to be entrusted with my  character  careful sir  can we come they're investigating the  murder of Leo copernic signs of a  struggle actually so I believe that  happened when Mrs Boyle was killed oh  there's that woman in the front brow  there  but she seems to have bounced back  surge's character she won't stop talking  you don't mind if I pick your Brian's  DSR it's like a drill in his forehead  you know sounds painful Sam and I have  just absolutely adored each other from  the very beginning it's  a joy to share a frame with her it's  amazing  well done okay  [Music]